[Musique]
oh
combien d'entre vous ici réalisent
qu'ils font probablement partie de l'une
des dernières générations d'humains à
cohabiter avec des grands singes des
éléphants des rhinocéros défaut combien
parmi vous ont pris conscience que d'ici
la fin de leur vie tous ici
l'intégralité de nos océans sera
probablement vidé de ses poissons pour
ceux qui ont des enfants
combien ont entrepris de leur dire de
bien regarder les oiseaux les insectes
et poissons les amphibiens car ils sont
tous en train de disparaître à une
vitesse vertigineuse
ces questions sont lourdes peu entre
mais c'est notre réalité
avez vous remarqué comme les médias
journaux radios télés ont tendance à se
féminiser les causes de cette tragédie
on parle d'extinction des espèces
d'effondrement du vivant de disparition
de la biodiversité
un peu comme si les causes n'étaient pas
bien établies
un peu comme si les animaux
disparaissait tout seul or nous avons
tous ici
l'implacable réalité nous sommes nous
des humains
la principale cause de ce qu'il faut
bien appeler une extermination du monde
sauvage
ma conviction c'est que nous sommes en
guerre en guerre contre les animaux
depuis toujours et que l'ultime bataille
que nous leur livrons aujourd'hui
pourrait nous être fatal comme elle
pourrait être la dernière chance d'un
sursaut de nos consciences pour vivre en
harmonie
parce que nos vies sont liées sans
animaux nous n'aurons pas de futur
laissez-moi vous partager ce point de
vue cet homme
dire moi s'appelait wine l'auteur l'état
sud africain il a consacré l'intégralité
de sa vie à la protection des animaux
sauvages notamment des éléphants en
tanzanie où elle l'auteur était dans un
taxi qui le ramenait de l'aéroport à son
hôtel
un peu avant minuit le 16 août 2017
lorsqu'un véhicule à a stoppé le sien un
homme en est sorti a ouvert sa portière
l'a abattu de deux balles avec sa
fondation one l'auteur avait contribué à
l'arrestation d'environ 900 braconniers
et autres trafiquants d'ivoire
il avait bien sûr pour cela reçu de
multiples menaces de mort est mise à
exécution vous souvenez aussi
probablement de diane fossey assez connu
elle a eu le crâne défoncé dans la
jungle du congo pour avoir voulu
préserver les derniers gorilles des
montagnes
djordje adamson lui s'est fait tué en
défendant les lions au kenya emmanuel de
mérode a eu plus de chance
tombé dans une embuscade blessé par
balles en 2004 il s'en est sorti
il continue à veiller sur les derniers
grands singes paul watson bien connu ici
le fondateur de sea shepherd est
toujours sous le coup d'un mandat
d'arrêt international en raison de son
engagement en faveur des cétacés
s'opposent s'opposer à ceux qui traquent
les animaux et qui exploite le vivant te
conduire aux pires extrémités
mais ce constat n'est pas simplement
valable pour les personnalité
charismatique et médiatique dont je
viens de parler chaque année en afrique
plus d'une centaine de ranger ce sont
tués par des braconniers ou tombent dans
l'exercice de leur activité
c'est pour les protéger et lutter contre
le braconnage intensif en afrique que
mon ami serge lopez a créé l' ong
françaises wild life
enjoy j'ai l'honneur et la chance d'en
être le vice-président depuis maintenant
sa création la réalité que vivent nos
équipes opérationnelles sur le terrain
est effroyable
qui traque les animaux désormais à coude
hélicoptère de grenades de kalachnikovs
et ils n'hésitent plus à tuer tous ceux
qui s'interpose sur leur chemin nous
sommes bien en situation de guerre
totale le trafic d'animaux sauvages
devenue l'une des principales sources de
financement du crime organisé depuis 15
ans un million de pangolin ont été tués
pour leur chair ou leurs écailles chaque
année vingt mille éléphants sont
massacrés pour leur ivoire un rhinocéros
tombent toutes les 8 minutes pour sa
corne
on parle beaucoup des requins à la
réunion onze mille cinq cent d'entre eux
sont capturées toutes les heures dans
les océans du monde pour leurs ailerons
le trac
bien que sur béziers attisé n'est pas la
principale cause de cette hécatombe des
animaux sauvages dans cette guerre il y
à de multiples fronts vous connaissez
tous l'agriculture intensive
l'étalement urbain la construction
d'infrastructures
la surpêche les pollutions diverses et
bien sûr le réchauffement climatique
tout cela nous y contribuer et tout cela
contribue à détruire de plus en plus la
biodiversité et les animaux qui la
composent même dans les endroits les
pulls vierge de présence humaine
ici par exemple la réunion à 3500 km au
sud dans les terres australes françaises
le changement global provoquée par
l'homme aura décimé en 30 ans 90% de la
plus grande colonie de manchots royaux
du monde
cette guerre est bien une guerre totale
et nous en sommes tous ici les complices
nous en sommes les héritiers car cette
guerre ne date pas d'hier nous avons
tendance à idéaliser club le premier est
à considérer qu'il vivait en totale
harmonie avec la nature
or les chasseurs cueilleurs ont été les
premiers à déclencher cette guerre
contre la nature
il y à 50 mille ans vivait en effet sur
terre gigantesque oiseaux herbivores
géants manie faire exceptionnel
marsupiaux et tortueux puis sont arrivés
les aborigènes les amérindiens les
tribus l'asie centrale qui malgré
technologie rudimentaire ont marqué de
leur empreinte l'ensemble des continents
ils ont décimé l'ensemble de cette faune
bouleversé la flore en profondeur
modifier le climat
le mythe écologistes du bon sauvage
gardiens de la nature n'a aucun
fondement l'humain est en fait en fait
l'espèce invasive ultime et toutes
espèces invasives prospère dans un
milieu où elle ne rencontre plus de
prédateurs
or nous n'avons plus de prédateurs nous
avons même réussi à maintenir à distance
les derniers virus et bactéries qui
pourraient nuire
notre expansion n'a plus d'autre limite
que celle de la planète
après avoir conquis les terres sauvages
nous ravages s'étend dorénavant à nos
plaines à nos montagnes à nos campagnes
ces trente dernières années 80 pour cent
des insectes ont disparu de nos
campagnes
un tiers des oiseaux autant d'amphibiens
de ces disparitions d'animaux de cette
sixième extinction démarré il ya
cinquante mille ans nous sommes donc
bien des coupables
héritier mais aussi des complices ici et
maintenant
bien sûr nous ne nous nourrissons plus
de mammouth au quotidien nous ne tuons
plus autant de bison pour nous vêtir de
leur peau ni même ne massacre des
baleines pour éclairer les rues grâce à
leur graisse mais nous avons créé pire
pour perpétuer l'oeuvre de nos ancêtres
nous avons industrialisé l'extermination
du vivant notre art de la guerre mise en
oeuvre il ya dix mille ans est sans
cesse améliorées depuis la domestication
nous sommes passés du loup et au chien
de l'apache ii le rock à la vache du
sanglier aux cochons nous avons soulevé
recéder ligne et modifier des jeunes
nous avons transformé par sélection
artificielle les animaux pour hausser
leur niveau de productivité de viande de
lait pour diminuer leur agressivité pour
augmenter leur taille pour favoriser
leur résistance aux maladies
nous avons construit des fermes usines
et des abattoirs géants et les animaux
sont devenus nos éternels prisonniers de
guerre nous leur avons assigné une
fonction mourir pour nous nourrir chaque
née notre alimentation planifient la
mort de plus de 60 milliards d'animaux
terrestres et de plus de 1000 milliards
de poisson rien qu'en france nos
traditions culinaires coûte la vie
chaque jour à 50 millions d'animaux
ces chiffres dépassent l'entendement
l'élevage et la pêche génère plus de
morts en une semaine
en une semaine que l'ensemble de toutes
les victimes humaines de toutes les
guerres de l'histoire de l'humanité nous
sommes d'impitoyables terminator nous ne
représentons que 0 01 % de la biomasse
terrestre mais nous sommes parvenus à
éradiquer
83% des mammifères il ne reste
aujourd'hui sur terre qu entre 3 et 4%
de mammifères sauvages trois quart de
tous les oiseaux du monde sont des
volailles d'élevage deux tiers de tous
les mammifères sont du bétail vaches
cochons ici qu'elle
années peut-être une ou deux décennies
un peu plus peut-être le dernier plus
gros mammifères sur terre sera une vache
sélectionné peut-être clonés en tous les
cas jouer à l'abattoir nous aurons
réussi à éradiquer sur une échelle de
temps dérisoires les centaines de
millions d'années d'évolution
cette guerre contre les animaux est
totalement absurde injuste et immorale
absurde car elle se retourne contre nous
depuis le 19eme grâce aux travaux
d'alexander von humboldt nous
connaissons les grandes lois de
l'écologie nous savons que la force et
la vitalité d'un éco système repose sur
sa diversité que toutes les espèces sont
interconnectés et qu'il existe une
limite à la capacité de charge d'une
planète aux ressources finies l'histoire
de la vie sur terre et celle de la
multitude d'interactions qui existe
entre toutes les espèces qui la
composent en négligeant notre
interdépendance avec la nature en
nuisant ainsi à la fonctionnalité des
écosystèmes qui supporte la vie cette
guerre aussi est totalement injuste car
nous savons aujourd'hui que les animaux
sont des êtres sentions comme nous ils
éprouvent de la peine de la joie de la
douleur de l'empathie et surtout n'ont
pas envie de mourir
nous ne pouvons plus nier ce que nous
dit la science entre l'homme et l'animal
n'existe pas une différence de nature
simplement 2 degrés laissez moi vous
rappeler quelque chose de nombreuses
recherches ont privé quand on ont
démontré pardon entre l'homme et
l'animal existait de très nombreuses
similitudes en matière de commissions de
rapport à leur environnement de
perception du monde et qu'en fonction de
leur espèce certains animaux était doué
de facultés mentales et d'une conscience
exceptionnel on sait par exemple
aujourd'hui et c'est prouvé que les
vaches m résoudre des énigmes que les
porcs peuvent apprendre à se laver que
les poissons la mémoire ou que les
poules savent calculer
à partir du moment où on sait ça comment
pouvons nous supporter et d'envoyer nos
semblables à l'abattoir et de les manger
d'autant plus que nous n'avons plus
besoin de leur chair
nourrir c'est prouvé au moins en
occident
enfin cette bière est totalement immoral
car nous traitons les animaux comme des
objets au service des humains
or ils ont une valeur intrinsèque
indépendamment des services qui nous
rendent disposer de leur vie comme bon
nous semble constituer un déni de leur
existence
non décidément il devient supportable de
traiter animaux comme nous le faisons
qu'ils soient domestiques ou qu'ils
soient sauvages
nous devons de mettre fin absurde
immoral et injuste à la fois par intérêt
bien compris comme par sens de l'éthique
ou tout simplement par humanité de fer
est bien la première chose que nous
pouvons faire c'est d'être cohérent du
moment où on a pris conscience de cette
tragédie qui nous entraîne tous
collectivement vers l'impasse ne plus
refus ne plus supporter d'accepter cette
souffrance et cette exploitation là
quelque chose de très simple que chacun
d'entre vous peut faire du jour au
lendemain et qui peut faire une énorme
différence
arrêtez tout simplement de manger de la
viande qu'est ce que j'ai fait il ya
quelques années comme des centaines de
millions d'autres zones des deux femmes
sur cette planète végétariens ou
végétaliens et qui ne s'en porte pas
plus mal
bien au contraire il ya un deuxième
effet kiss cool as a refusé de fuir
notre conscience de massifs sur la
réduction de notre empreinte écologique
faux de penser
la deuxième chose que
pouvons faire c'est d'essayer d'en
convaincre nos proches leur donner à
réfléchir disputé avec leur ouvrir les
yeux sur sa stratégie tragédie dont nous
sommes les coupables héritiers et les
complices bien sûr c'est très compliqué
ça renvoie à une certaine forme de juste
de dénonciation sacrés du malaise
certains le prennent violemment remet en
cause leur intimité leur rapport à la
convivialité ce qu'ils aiment partager
avec leurs amis leur famille qui voire
même leur tradition je comprends il faut
dorénavant changer nos imaginaires si
nous voulons nous sauver nous mêmes la
troisième chose que nous pouvons faire
c'est nous engager nous engager contre 6
système qui exploite opprime et tu
l'ensemble des écosystèmes qui nous sont
indispensables
nous allons nous engager contre
l'industrie agroalimentaire contre les
abattoirs que la chasse contre le
braconnage entre le trafic
c'est violent ça sera difficile
l'arsenal répressif sera de plus en plus
fort pour préserver système ordre établi
et nous avons dorénavant besoin d co
variole enfin la quatrième chose que
nous pouvons faire c'est rêver rêver
d'un monde où la cohabitation avec les
animaux ne se solde pas par un massacre
rêver d'un monde où de nouvelles règles
puissent être établies pour vivre en
harmonie
ce monde will kymlicka et sous donaldson
l'on imaginait dans leurs oeuvres
je vous conseille de lire qui s'appelle
0 police dans cette oeuvre
il propose d'étendre les droits humains
aux animaux en conférant par exemple une
certaine forme de citoyenneté aux
animaux domestiques
c'est beaucoup moins inimaginable qu'il
n'y paraît et c'est drôlement excitant
pour repenser un modèle totalement
obsolète
le rêve d' edward wilson s'être autre
écrivain a rédigé un ouvrage qui
s'appelle half earth où il suggère de
réserver somme soit risée de cette
adaptation façon la moitié des terres de
l'humaine de cette planète pour les
animaux sauvages leur président
permettant ainsi de préserver la
fonctionnalité des écosystèmes qui
garantissent la vie pour tous charles
d'art
win nous a enseigné que l'homme et
l'animal avait des origines communes
nous ne sommes pas supérieur aux autres
êtres vivants
nous sommes parmi eux en revanche nous
avons une faculté unique celle de
réfléchir de produire des abstractions
d'imaginer des concepts cela ne nous
rend pas plus intelligent ni supérieur
une fois de plus mais cela nous oblige
vis-à-vis de nous-mêmes et nous donne
une responsabilité particulière
vis-à-vis des autres êtres vivants sur
cette planète
nous avons su nous attaquer au sexisme à
l'esclavagisme au racisme il est plus
que temps de mettre un terme à la plus
grande entreprise d'oppression et
d'exploitation de tous les temps le
spécisme cette idéologie qui stipule la
supériorité de l'espèce humaine sur
toutes les autres en guise de conclusion
je paraphrase ray cette phrase du bar is
nous menons une guerre contre les
animaux si nous la gagnons nous sommes
perdus
merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]